tel bordel
[Musique]
je vous emmène avec moi aujourd'hui on
est au sud de l'espagne si vous avez
suivi pendant ces deux derniers jours on
est à punta umbria pour l'ifa l'ifa qui
fait sa grande conférence de presse avec
trois cents journalistes venus du monde
entier
donc on parle de plein de choses entre
al d'électroménager on parle de plein de
produits donc c'est plutôt cool mais
aujourd'hui je vous parle pas des trois
villages et je fais tout montrer ou
trois trucs vous allez voir ça c'est
sympa et la conf de presse qui va
commencer d'ici vingt minutes contre de
presse globale mais samedi quand je
tourne je vous parle aujourd'hui du mil
neuf et ce c'est un smartphone qui était
présenté il ya quelques jours à paris
par le chien a omis c'est le petit frère
du mineur qui était présenté à barcelone
ça nous fait quand même beaucoup bougé
entre séville entre barcelone on voyage
aux maldives à plein de choses
intéressantes et donc aujourd'hui mis
neuf et ce alors ça fait un petit moment
que je le prends que je fais des photos
que je le texte que vous dire ce que
j'en pense là regardez là derrière moi
vous avez l'entrée de l'hôtel
et là vous avez marqué il faille
faudrait que je regarde c'est là la
voilà il fa
les drapeaux qui flottent on est plutôt
pas mal
[Musique]
donc là il ya la conférence de presse
globale qui va commencer dans quelques
instants
bon je vais vous passer ça parce que ça
va vraiment vous intéresser regardez je
vous montre un peu les couilles j'avais
la scène qui est juste la grande salle
et moi j'ai perdu mes collègues qui sont
partis s'installer au fond petit compte
de presse pour parler de l'ifa qui va
arriver que vous emmener avec moi au
mois de septembre on va aller voir leaf
pas on va y avoir toutes les nouveautés
qui vont se passer les coûts
technologiques grand public
donc je vous invite dès maintenant à
vous abonner trouve très intéressante
alors bon ça dure un peu plus de deux
ans mais déjà c'est cool non c'est
notamment qu' à richard et ue qui est le
big boss de wafa la première contre du
de l'ifa ça va être sympa il y aura
aussi des scènes allemandes de coin
comme fabricant pas mal d'acteurs on
voit que le japon sera vraiment à
l'honneur cette fois ci elle ne va
comment un peu les tendances de ce qui
se passe ça c'est vraiment cool bon tout
ça on dort cendrars à l'ifa au mode
septembre tranquillement pour l'instant
et je vais vous parler justement du
shérif
le laissez moi vous parler du chai au
mit mit 9 s e déjà ce que j'aime bien
avec ce smartphone c'est ce côté hyper
compact on est sur un écran de 5,97
pouces ce qui est bien et ce qui change
par rapport à d'autres smartphones c'est
qu'effectivement il est beaucoup plus
petit c'est un peu la question à
laquelle a répondu chez omis pour ses
mille fans c'est mes fans me disant on a
toujours des smartphones avec des écran
beaucoup plus grand à quelque chose de
plus petit de plus compact facile à
tenir dans la main et là c'est vraiment
ce qu'ils ont voulu faire avec ce
smartphone
un modèle qui est petit qui s'inscrit
plus dans la ligne des 5,8 pouces de ce
qu'on va retrouver notamment sur un
iphone 10s 15.6 pouces comme un google
pixels 3 également un smartphone on
tient facilement dans la main qu'on peut
utiliser à une main et ça c'est
intéressant c'est ce qu'en feront sur ce
smartphone à smartphone que je trouve
pour ma part assez compact assez légers
faciles à utiliser à une main et de ce
point de vue là je trouve qu'en tout cas
le pari vraiment réussie de la partie
shiomi c'est en tout cas une des vraies
belles qualités de ce smartphone en plus
court que le design est bien assez bien
léché bien réussie de la part de schumi
est fait que vous ayez pas de capteur
d'empreinte digitale au dos et bien on
retrouve sous l'écran alors ça peut être
bien et pas bien il se déverrouille
assez rapidement mais ce n'est pas non
plus complètement fou des fois il ya un
petit peu de mal il faut vraiment bien
positionné son doigt en face pour qu'ils
se déverrouille c'est un peu le problème
des smartphones avec des capteurs
d'empreintes digitales optique
des fois c'est voilà oui là il a réussi
des fois c'est pas complètement ça alors
ici je veux vraiment poussé là la
luminosité à fond on est en plein soleil
on est en andalousie
il fait extrêmement beau et fait
extrêmement chaud vous vous le voyez
peut-être pas travers de l'écran mais
moi comme ça je le vois relativement
bien je trouve que l'écran est assez
lumineuse où je vous parle justement
cette question de soleil d'exposition ça
tombe bien qu'on soit ici en plein
cagnard l'andalousie c'est justement il
ya un mode soleil vous avez une mode
soleil 2.0 et dessus ça c'est un truc
qui est vraiment intéressant là on est à
la proche de l'été donc lorsque vous y
retrouver en extérieur en pas soleil
vous pouvez compter sur lui plutôt bien
sûr on a donc un produit qui est assez
compact l'écran est correct pour venir
visionner des vidéos ça marche bien vous
avez une toute petite encoche sur le
dessus c'est la petite encoche goudeau
personnellement ça me dérange pas non
plus un menton qui est un peu plus grand
mais bon on est sur un smartphone qui
est pas très cher on peut pas trop lui
en vouloir
pour moi en tout cas du point de vue
format du point de vue
cran ça va il fait la faire pour
regarder du contenu multimédia ça
fonctionne aussi plutôt pas mal en point
et venir obtenir ou même un petit peu
ici voyez vous avez la petite encoche
sur le côté alors bon soin s'est pas
complètement idéal c'est pas non plus
hyper agréable à voir la tendance vient
plutôt à ce que les écrans deviennent de
plus en plus grands et que ces petites
protubérances le côté disparaissent ça
arrivera aussi tout doucement chez
xiaomi même sur les modèles milieu de
gamme
je trouve que l'écran est globalement
assez bien comme il ya une mine et c'est
sympa pour regarder du contenu vidéo
c'est pas mal c'est assez agréable en
termes de gaming ça fonctionne aussi on
n'a pas un tout qui complètement ouf
mais ça marche c'est assez sympa alors
envoyé un peu joie des petits jeux comme
à sac ni trompeuse voit déjà un peu plus
gourmand qui paye bg dans l'absolu ça va
ça fonctionne
bon vous en dit pas non peut avoir le
top performances au niveau des
graphismes on n'est pas sur le
smartphone le plus performant le plus
puissant mais pour vous permettre de
jouer à un certain nombre de jeux dans
l'absolu ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal on
n'a définitivement pas le smartphone le
plus performant en écartant une dragonne
712 et si giga de ram néanmoins je
trouve assez fluide pour l'utilisation
courante pour tout ce que vous avez à
vos applications maintenant que de
multitâche ça fonctionnera ça ira
parfaitement bien
on est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme
on laissera soit celle qui coûte j'ai lu
prix très exact ici en version 6
gigabits 64 go de stockage 369 et 399
euros si vous voulez monter en 128 gb de
stockage donc bon à ce prix là vous
avoir truqué honnête et correct par pas
mal de choses avec sans en faire trop
et qu'en est-il en termes de photos vous
avez comme sur le grand modèle comme sur
le 1920 sur 2009 est ce un triple
capteur photo alors vous retrouvez avec
un capteur principal de 48 mégapixels
c'est la fameuse caméra la sony à 1586
qui normalement soin papier est assez
bonne en conditions de faible luminosité
gilles normalement parce que vous allez
voir que ce n'est pas forcément ça ça
fait le job quand même rassuré vous qui
vous permet d'avoir quatre pixels en un
an gros sur les 48 mégapixels vous allez
prendre quatre gros pixels c'est pour
capter plus de lumière et ça vous
restituera une image 12 mégapixels donc
normalement en termes de faible
luminosité
c'est un peu mieux vous avez un tel
objectif de 8 mégapixels et un
grand-angle 123° de 13 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 et à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de cette fille cachée ici dans
l'encoche de 20 mégapixels alors qu'est
ce qu'on a en résultat en photo là
dessus alors je vous disais en termes de
photos de nuit s'est pas complètement
sain une fois de plus on va le resituer
dans son prix on est à moins de 400
euros on n'est pas sur le photophone de
ouf pour faire des photos de nuit
à côté de ça est ce que vous faites
beaucoup des photos de nuit quand
j'entends photo nuisent lui aussi photo
en faible luminosité c'est à dire que
dès que vous arrivez dans une pièce qu
un petit peu sont un peu obscure c'est
un peu moins son truc à ce smartphone
par contre lorsque vous avez des
conditions comme ça avec une belle
lumière là c'est un vrai régal
le capteur de 48 mégapixels fait un
boulot qui est parfaitement maîtrisée
qui est même merveilleux je vous
montrais peu cliché c'est franchement
génial il ya aussi une différence en
termes de colorimétrie mais ça c'est
normal sur la partie grand angle et sur
la partie normale sans le retrouve
sensiblement sur tous les capteurs donc
là-dessus il n'y a pas de souci à se
faire il ya rien à reprocher à ce
smartphone
ça fait le job vous avez un grand temps
de 123 degrés ça vous permet sans savoir
beaucoup de recul de capter des choses
très grande
si vous voulez capter des édifices
voulait capter pas mal du tout
c'est assez intéressant le téléobjectif
aussi fonctionne bien sans savoir un
résultat complètement fou on est sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme on va pas
s'attendre à des résultats qui vont être
complètement hallucinant en termes de
photos qu'il faut vraiment retenir sur
ce produit au niveau de la photographie
c'est toutes les photos dès lors vous
avez beaucoup lumière le résultat sera
vraiment impeccable bien évidemment il
ya de la reconnaissance de scène ya de
l'intelligence artificielle derrière il
va capable de détecter si vous voulez
photographier de la nourriture un
paysage un humain il va adapter la
colorimétrie en fonction de toutes
sortes
bon maintenant il ya un truc qui est pas
complètement fou c'est l'autonomie vous
avez une batterie de 3000 70 millions
terreur alors il y à des smartphones
très haut de gamme qui ont des batteries
qui sont pas plus grosse voire
légèrement plus petit mais c'est vrai
que de ce point de vue là l'autonomie
est pas complètement folle vous avez
gardé votre smartphone une journée une
journée sans aucun preuve alors après ça
dépend complètement de votre usage si
vous êtes tout le temps dessus pendant
des heures prolongées
il ya un moment l'autonomie ça va être
aussi un petit peu moins ça néanmoins
vous l'aurez une journée et guère plus à
moins que vous n'utilisiez quasiment pas
ou quelqu'un vous à venir d'un peu plus
voilà c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut
retenir sur ce smartphone c'est que
l'autonomie est pas complètement
dernière à côté de ça vous avez de la
recharge 18 watts une recherche qui est
assez rapide vous le mettez une des
meilleures charge et vous êtes reparti
pour un bon moment donc bon ça s'est
relativement bien il se recharge
rapidement et ça c'est un point qui est
aussi relativement important parce que
le fait de pas voir une énorme autonomie
en soit ça fait toujours aller mais si
vous savez qu'en phase autres
smartphones vous allez le recharger
rapidement et
vous trouvez une prise paf vous êtes
relativement tranquille c'est un point
qui rassure sans un point qui est
important qui à mon avis est un point
majeur sur ce smartphone point de vue os
en trombe sur me why certains aimeront
certains non c'est vraiment une question
de goût personnel l'audio est correct
pour le multimédia ça fonctionnera ça
sera correct voilà pour pouvoir écouter
de la musique pour pouvoir profiter de
quelques jeux ça fera le job s'est pas
complètement dingue que vous avez du nfc
dessus ça c'est pas mal pour le paiement
dématérialisé pour l'utiliser pour
notamment le pass navigo pour les pour
les parisiens pour que notre application
en gros ce qu'il faut retenir avec ce
smartphone c'est que on est je dirais
sur une version en dessous par rapport
aux 1900 vous vous en douterez est ce
special edition ou small edition serait
pas réellement quelle est la définition
qu'il faut vraiment retenir c'est qu'on
a un format qui est compact on est un
smartphone qui est honnête vous pourrez
faire plein de choses avec c'est pas le
smartphone le plus exigeant mais c'est
un smartphone qui est bien si on m'y a
fait un boulot qui est intéressant
dessus ça permet d'avoir une énième
smartphone dans la gamme qui vient se
positionner face à beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de produits dans cette gamme de
prix
c'est un marché qui est très compliqué
mais même si on me se met en concurrence
à certains de ses modèles qui ont pu
baisser en prix face et c'est
intéressant tout cas c'est une
proposition qui est pas mal je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez vous et comment
vous le trouvez par rapport aux mineurs
fatim ans on a perdu un peu de spec à un
peu moins bien bossé on sera moins
performant mais dans l'absolu si vous
avez pas d usage de dengue et si vous
n'êtes pas hyper exigeants pour moi
c'est un smartphone qui est vraiment
intéressant
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire moi je trouve cool et là
maintenant je vous emmène avec moi là on
est à je voulais dire au sud de séville
on à punta umbria dans quelques-uns
avoir lieu le dîner de gala le temps
pour moi d'enfiler une chemise g63 fer à
repasser je suis pas encore trouvé voir
si si je peux leur passé sinon ça va
être moyen moyen vous emmène avec moi
soit réduit à l'année puis vous me direz
ce que vous en pensez en bas let's go
lles bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle
nouvelle bonne nouvelle c'est un peu la
gagne à regarder hop
regardez ce que j'ai réussi à trouver un
petit faire il est froid
il est faire il est froid le faire le
faire et là la chemise est là et reste
plus qu'à les faire travailler ensemble
des bourses au point de vue anormalement
jeux pas trop mauvais
et puis on parle dans quelques instants
à la soirée
[Musique]
donc là je vous amener avec moi c'est
soirée de gala dit pas on est dans un
monastère
c'est combien thiam siècle c'est assez
courant fait puisque préserver ses
magnifiques notamment sur les gars là où
on va les manger dans un endroit il faut
que derrière il y installe ou solo enfin
je sais tu pas quoi ça va ressembler
l'histoire mais c'est hyper hyper
impressionnant
[Musique]
le truc elle juste complètement fou on
est dans
chapelle dans une église il ya tout le
monde à table c'est le dîner de gala
l'art
c'est
assez improbable assez incroyable la vue
est
je kiffe vol c'est tout